another segment that we love to do on
this show which i can honestly say today
feels like such a luxury and a privilege
um
is uh of course our food
[Music]
news um there is an la institution at
this desk today
this hot dog dynasty has been serving
hollywood hot dogs since 1939
and it is still going strong on the
corner of la brea and melrose i am
honored as someone who grew up in 1975
right around the corner
from pink's hot dogs
from pink is gloria and beverly pink
i'll take it i'll take it
here you go oh my god
those are some really big wieners this
is our newest most favorite hot dog it's
the drew's news dog and it's officially
on the menu
we're going to have a true news hot dog
on our menu i think i
first of all i can't believe that we get
to be
a part of the institution for pinks i
mean
i was first of all the history is so
fascinating your family migrated from
russia right romania and romania and
russia opened up the hot dog stand as a
cart yes it was a push cart
and they were lucky in those days to
serve 50 a day today we serve about 2
000 dogs a day wow i was just going to
ask 82 years in business how do you do
it you do it by selling 2 000 hot dogs a
day that's right that's right and we are
humbled and honored that people will
wait in line for those dogs right
because it is an iconic institution and
michelle obama has come there yes that
was a funny story because we were
actually beverly and i were there
because japanese tv was showing up to
talk about pinks and somebody came up to
me and showed me his credentials
they were the secret service
they said somebody very important is
going to be here in about 20 minutes and
we said who is it and they said if you
live on this planet you'll know who it
is and it was michelle obama and her
daughters and her mother and then uh
bruce willis proposed to demi moore
there exactly really yeah
it hit all the trade papers yeah and
another one michael j fox got his call
for family ties on the pay phone that
was in front of pinks for reals he used
to hang out so much at pinks that he
referred to pinks as his office and got
the call to be alex p keaton right then
and there exactly yeah that's a
legendary style the p stands for pinks
yeah
can i just ask what's on a drew's news
hot dog yes this is our giant 12-inch
jalapeno dog filled with jalapenos so it
got a kick
a little bit just like the news mustard
onions our famous pink's chili
shredded cheddar cheese and bacon
i
love it quite a feast quite a delight we
love pinks and we're so happy the pink's
family is back and it is going strong
opening after the pandemic the lines are
continuing around the block thank you so
much
thank you
a hot dog is not a sandwich
thank you for saying it seth i just
can't thank you enough for gracing us
with your presents i'm sure you have a
lot of requests no i'm very happy to be
here but you know what seth i'll say
this it ain't no fun without the bun
[Music]